[Music]
Jordan have asked you to review some of
your favorite products let's take a look
at one well the product I want to talk
about is the norelco body groom of BG
two zero three eight this is my own
personal unit now this product uses a
lithium ion battery which is at full
power after only a one hour charge its
predecessor the BG 20/20 use a nickel
metal hydride battery which required
overnight eight hour charge to be at
full power you're clinically insane it's
incredibly versatile in terms of hair
removal and can work on many different
areas of the body I use this product
daily I'm sorry this is you this is your
personal one right here at this one
right this this one yeah I have to Louie
just push that over here then I want to
be near that what are the reason that's
been all over your body right yeah okay
let's just keep it over there and touch
my body take my hand yeah I don't think
you've been I'm okay with shaking your
hand but this has been down near your
pubis as it not I'd like that to remain
personal has it just answered my
question now I've noticed hair on many
areas of your body that I think would be
well-served by this product okay when
have you noticed hair on my body
seriously there's been many occasions
you and I were in a hotel room in Las
Vegas 2004 and you took your shirt off
you had a disgusting patch of red hair
at the base of your back did you really
just say that I a patch of you said
disgusting red hair on the base of my
back there is a bush at the base of your
that's absolutely unbelievable that you
would say that on television are you
saying it's not true
I don't know first of all I don't think
it's a bush I think I probably have some
red hairs I have a copper colored my
body hair is a copper colored hair I'm a
redhead
have you removed the hair why were you
looking down there in the first place
what was the circumstance where I took
my shirt off and I was with you in a
Vegas hotel room what was happening you
were getting changed okay so you were
watching me while I got changed I was
paying you the respect who deserved as
we were in a conversation and I took my
shirt off and why did you look down at
the base of my back or the top of my
buttocks where were you staring your
interpretation of the area is under
printing anything are you happy with the
bush of red hair at the base of your
back well extend
you don't have to pull your pants down
what's that you don't have to I didn't
you did now the places now go okay
you're how far down are you going wait
don't stop you're not done
well I've completed the task no no keep
going you're back you're back there it's
not my drop trou shave a little lower
please now you have to do the whole
thing I believe you have the Didache
dexterity very what's happening now
doctor
I'm cleaning up some of the small areas
I've missed okay
now can't you see the benefits of this
product in your everyday life a little
more I've completed the task no more I
don't recommend shaving your buttock
hair do you it's a personal matter so
you saved my low back towards your
buttocks how close did you get to the
fissure as it were where these hair
starts and the hair ends there's a
transition and mother nature makes that
transition very natural however will be
interfere with mother nature sometimes
it looks a bit artificial I feel I have
left you with natural-looking upper
buttock you're the strangest person I've
ever met
morally I professionally interview three
people a day I've been doing it four or
five days a week for 23 years you're the
strangest man I've ever met Jordan what
other areas do you shave besides your
buttocks well uh like I said this can be
used on area any area that you wish to
remove here you may want to remove hair
on your legs your arms your ears you
do you shave your green alaria well I
don't want to talk about any personal
matters but I'll tell you in my case a
good demonstration of the abilities of
this product would be the chest area
this is the body I was given in the
situation that I'm dealing with no I
recognize this this is the standard
photo of disgraced senators this is this
has taken many a politician down here's
the after shot
I recognize this photograph yes this was
the cover of the March issue of
douchebag magazine this isn't Robin I
didn't stand nobody's getting paid to
promote those products right completely
those were products Jordans obsessed
with no money's changing hands we won't
accept any money
that's just Jordan and I just had to
make that very clear right alright are
you itching where the hair is growing
back it did take something off of that
yeah yeah yeah I don't stand up straight
anymore
[Laughter]
you